hey guys today we are unboxing something
extremely exciting I'm not sure if you
guys follow vacuum news or not and if
you don't you probably should start
because it's actually my favorite
pastime I'm not even joking
which makes this video even more
exciting for me because dyson partnered
with me to unbox one of their brand new
vacuums this is the Dyson cyclone v10
absolute so thank you so much Dyson for
sponsoring this video cuz I swear this
is like a dream come true
and if you've ever used a cord free
vacuum you might know that the suction
power of these is not usually comparable
to some of the upright corded ones well
that's where this is replacing
everything because this basically is
replacing it why is this not me oh this
this I want that to be me I just feel
like I'm moving the box around and not
really so this thing has been completely
all redesigned there's a bigger bin
which means more cleaning you guys I
don't know if you've ever unboxed a new
vacuum before but it is really exciting
especially if you have a dog
granted my dog doesn't shed but he
brings in basically everything that he
can find outside inside I feel like I'm
gonna need a bigger table open all of
these things just just get out
everything oh there's two different
attachments so I oh yeah this is
industrial this is what I'm talking
about
okay think I got everything out digital
motor of v10 it spins up to 125 thousand
rpms right 20% more suction 20% smaller
and have the weights Wow tell me your
secret this is me this is my future this
looks like it's a wall mount there's
directions
here's instructions on how to mount the
little charging dock looks pretty simple
here is our charger if you already have
a v7 or v8 you can also use those
attachments with this new heat head this
is one of the docking stations you can
run the cord up from here so it makes it
super easy to charge they still can't
believe how light this is
whoa I was not ready for that turn you
down let's take a look at some of the
attachments this comes with so this is
one of these fluffy attachments as you
can see here it's really funky and you
can use this if you're picking up bigger
things I've never used one of these
before so I'm super excited to try this
out because this is something that you
can use if you have like big chunks of
something that can you to pick up like
some spilled cereal for example or I
don't know anything that I happen to
make in my kitchen can't wait to try
this out oh this is like a little mini a
little mini attachment for handheld use
look at this okay let's open this guy up
I think that I officially know that I'm
an adult what I'm super excited about a
vacuum let's take a look at this thing
and see if we can get it all set up my
sister is gonna be so excited I'll be
sitting on her couch at her house and
she's vacuuming around me as I'm eating
leave me alone charged fully before use
all right I will do that it was sorry I
hid my camera but I want to get it all
set up and just see what it looks for we
charged up look at this
Wow oh yeah this is a beautiful sight I
know this was a charge at first but I
gotta try it out
Oh
I'm already picking up dirt I wanted to
just say clean I'm sorry beer that's
what you're for you guys want any more
information about the Dyson cyclone v10
absolute I will put a link in the
description I'm gonna go charge of this
thing up and then we're gonna give it a
test around the house
[Music]
[Applause]
oh boy this is the moment that I've been
waiting for finally time to test this
out I also ranked a GoPro onto this
because you know why not
the GoPros up here you guys are I'm
filming in 60 frames a second 4k see
guys can really get some great slow-mo
shots so I haven't put anything down on
this carpet this is just a week or so
worth of not cleanliness so let's give
it a clean and I'll see what we got
[Music]
[Applause]
these are some salt and vinegar chips
that I had the other day another problem
was having a black carpet and blonde
hair it's Jenna actually was using this
lens today she's cleaning your car out
and this is the fluffy one and it's my
favorite I've got a pretzel here let's
just put this on the floor shall we see
if it can handle these big guys get some
more snacks to put on the carpet oh this
is so fun I missed hmm doesn't matter so
you've got a few more attachments so
we're gonna try each one of these out on
a little bit of a mess and see how they
handle it oh my gosh I hate it I'm so
disgusted I hate it as so much even
though I'm not necessarily the most
organized person like I really don't
like messes even though my house
sometimes is a little bit messy it still
drives me absolutely crazy and this
right now I can't I hate it I'm so
disgusted by it but we've gotta clean it
up
[Music]
[Applause]
dress my house now
[Music]